bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouvel
épisode probablement aujourd'hui
j'accueille du coup il sait pas trop
comment tap les malades ont pu quitter
la chaîne youtube matin dans et
également du compte twitter armata dont
je peux citer aussi sur facebook tu te
supplie sur youtube et twitter
kaba bienvenu.merci est ce que tu peux
commencer par un peux te présenter un
peu ton parcours notamment scolaires
professionnels ouais ouais alors bas je
fais un parcours entre guillemets
classique je pense que tout ce qu'on
pense qui filent donc quoi j'ai fait un
bac s et puis arrivé au bac à ces
moments où tu sais pas où aller
j'avais des potes qui faisait métiers du
coup je me suis je faire médecine à et
c'était pas du tout pour moi c'est
vraiment ça demande beaucoup de travail
et ces deux conditions qui sont qui ne
correspondaient pas du coup je me suis
dit bon je vais aller en bio parce que
la bio c'est ce qu'a dû proche quoi à
quai et ouais là encore une fois je me
retrouve en duo par ailleurs je sais pas
trop non plus quoi faire
mais c'est plus progressif au fil des
années il ya des spécialisations qui
sont petit à petit au début j'ai le
choix entre bio animales ou végétales et
bio animal ça me tentait pas trop parce
que c'était l'expérience des tp les
dissections une touchette
je me suis dit je disséquer des plantes
qui saura et du coup voilà le me
retrouver dans un parcours bio végétal
accès environnement et
et bah ouais ça m'a plu de plus en plus
et je me suis pris une passion pour tout
ce qui est beau thani et que tout ce qui
est biologique végétale et et après j'ai
fait du coup donc j'ai eu ma licence à
et du coup je suis allé vers un master
pareil accès environnement et et
biologie végétale avec avec aussi une
grosse composante de de génétique et du
coup c'est là que j'ai commencé aussi à
rentrer dans toutes ces histoires de
génétique les ogm tout ça et du coup
j'ai fait des stages durent au masters
j'ai fait deux stages à l'inra j'ai fait
un stage ballack axes et l'axé génétique
génétique des plantes aux mots je
cherchais chercher un gène responsable
responsables de la résistance à une
maladie
et c'est ouais c'est le genre de chose
qui me plaît mois de voilà à chercher
des gènes chercher à quoi qu'est ce qui
cause si on touche c'est génial qu'est
ce que ça fait donc ça c'est ça j'aime
bien c'est par là de voir au niveau
génétique tout ce qui est contrôlé au
niveau génétique quoi et j'ai fait le
stage parce que du coup elle j'avais un
parcours axé l'écologie aussi je me suis
dit je me disais que l'écologie ça
plaisait aussi du coup j'ai fait un
deuxième stage c'est plutôt écologie
cette fois et là j'ai fait j'ai regardé
l'écologie chimique des plantes c'est à
dire là j'ai travaillé sur les molécules
ce qu'était par les plantes pour se
défendre contre les ravageurs les
herbivores et les interactions du coup
entre les plantes et les herbivores et
l'appareil aussi ça m'a vachement
intéressés mais je me suis dit que ce
n'était pas le genre de sujet sur lequel
je voulais travailler même si même si le
sujet est passionnant et donc du coup là
dans ma tête je me suis orienté plutôt
vers le même type de sujet que j'avais
fait dans mon premier et mon premier
stage hockey ou au c'est quelque chose
de plus génétique
donc voilà donc que j'ai tous bagram
dans en biologie végétale en génétique
de plantes hockey et tu as fait tes
études en france c'est ça j'ai fait les
ide ont froncé la balance au moment où
on suit ce week-end et en suisse a conçu
une thèse c'est ça
là oui je suis hanté les en suisse au
fait que même temps voilà j'ai commencé
il ya huit mois ok mais ça se passe bien
j'ai de bons résultats pour l'instant ça
va mais c'est quoi le sujet de la thèse
alors le sud de matériaux simples bonnes
gens c'est gégé une plante fourragère
ouais donc pour la nutrition du bétail
qui qui est sensible à une maladie et du
coup on essaie de trouver de trouver des
variétés qui serait réside dans cette
maladie donc j'ai déjà des variétés qui
sont résistantes mais on sait pas
pourquoi
j'essaie de voir de savoir quel est le
gène qui serait responsable de saïd anti
fils eugène trouvé sa fonction pourquoi
pourquoi sa cause une résistance
inquiète comprendre l'interaction aussi
avec le pathogène et c'est ok tu veux
comment faire pour retrouver ce jeune
fille de grossièrement en gros ce que ce
que j'ai une population qui qui est
différemment résistante à la maladie
j'en ai certains qui sont très
résistantes et certaines qui sont très
sensibles et du coup je fais des groupes
et celles qui sont très résistants je
vais comparer je vais les jouer les
projets toutes les séquences et je
regardais leur génome à tous leurs gènes
et je veux donc du coup je vais comparer
celle qui sont très résistantes à celles
qui sont très sensibles et du cou
normalement si le jet n'est pas
impliquée je serais censé avoir autant
de tous les allèles dans mes deux
populations
et si c'est un jeune qui a impliqué je
serais censé avoir un allèle qui serait
qui serait plus représenté dans une
population dans l'autre un qui accepte
parce que c'était là ce serait se
montrent responsables de de la
résistance ou de la sensibilité hockey
une crise beaucoup de séquençage voilà
j'ai pas encore commencé mais moi ça va
être beaucoup de séquences accueil parce
que du coup l'idée c'est si tu sais
quand ce qu'on vient de gemini
l'individu âgé
que j'ai fait du scoring donc où j'ai
donné un score de maladie de 1 à 5 en
étant très résistant et 5 c la pente
elle est morte
t'as fait ça là bas et je fais ça ouais
visuellement je regarde la blanche et
notes et j'en ai fait minutes comme sa
vie ni foie etc est un peu après sur le
séquençage c'est moins il ya moins
d'individus parce que je fais des choix
des pouges les regroupant en compé que
s'est construit en même temps une cote
c'est moins compliqué mais bon d'accord
et du coup elle doit du coup j'ai mis le
g8 individus j'ai passé conseiller les
villages de coups je fais des groupes et
je prends les mille plus résistant et
1000 plus sensibles d'accord pour les
extrêmes ça fait déjà pas mal de boulot
mais en attendant cet âge que tafer ou
peut-être aidé dans ses recherches et
les trucs qui t'ont déjà surpris eux
surpris pas vraiment pressé jeunesse à
ses geôles sait rien eu d'exceptionnel
non ok après après c'est toujours les
aléas de de la recherche
il ya toujours des choses auxquelles on
ne s'attend pas forcément il ya toujours
des dés la variabilité des choses qu'on
n'aimerait pas qu'on aimerait ne pas
avoir un accord comme quoi ben j'ai eu
des pucerons
du coup je suis censé regarder l'impact
d'une maladie etc j'ai une autre maladie
en plus c'est difficile à voir
ouais je vais aussi à m'en débarrasser
hockey puisque tu veux tu traites
spécialement pour les pucerons et moi
j'utilise un traitement spécifique pour
une seconde
ok c'est pas facile mais pas seulement
et du coup tu donc ils n'ont que tu
pense continuer à revivre un tat ça va
continuer à faire des expériences
similaires s'y trouvait donc des gènes
capables de lutter contre telle ou telle
maladie
c'est ça ouais j'ai la ccc une première
partie après je vais peut-être
m'orienter sur la bactérie qui cause la
maladie en elle-même est séquencée la
bactérie elles aussi pour voir s'il ya
des jeunes qui seraient qui serait
intéressant qui serait du coup
responsable de la maladie
après regardez peut-être au niveau de
l'expression des gènes 11 ans entendu du
rena sec donc on recommence et quand ce
n'est pas la dénoncer quand cela est
reine qui donc ce qui est exprimé depuis
les jeunes et qui va donner ensuite les
protéines ou ton pouvoir quels gènes
seraient plus exprimer quand la plante
est infecté et voir voici peut-être que
ce gel ne seraient impliqués aussi ok
d'accord
et du coup c'est une grosse comédie qui
travaillent sur ces questions c'est au
sur quatre questions on va essayer de
trouver des jeunes qui font la
résistance aux différentes maladies
oui ça c'est un peu la base de toute
l'amélioration
vérité dans le monde je pense après il
ya d'autres cas d'autres traits qu'on
essaie d'améliorer d'autre que la
résistance à des maladies h pas le roman
le goût les choses comme ça là mais
ouais la résistance à la maladie c'est
quelque chose d'assez important parce
que suivant la maladie c'est d'être
outil qui causent des pertes de jeu par
à 40 50 % en finlande dans les extrêmes
et c'est des trucs assez assez lourd
ouais donc voilà on essaie on essaie de
trouver des moyens de résister et
surtout enfin que la c6 on n'a pas ce
genre de vérité les moyens de résister
c'est des pesticides quoi donc ok parler
les pesticides c'est pas forcément le
diable mais si on peut les éviter c'est
quand même une bonne chose
ok ok puisque parce que du coup il donc
si si si ta recherche si tu arrives à
identifier les bons gènes
tu pourrais près donc des variétés qui
sont résistantes et ne plus avoir dit
mieux les pesticides et diminue aussi
les pertes c'est ça c'est ça ouais bon
après moi mon cas c'est un peu
particulier parce que c'est une bactérie
et du coup il n'y a pas de pesticides
contre les bactéries à part à berne et
les antibiotiques donc à utiliser les
antibiotiques c'est pas très recommandé
un quai dans les problèmes de résistance
de santé humaine et animale puisqu'en ce
moment c'est un type qui sont utilisés
ben non justement les utilise pas non
justement qu'à une place au rang des
pertes directement
ouais ouais c'est ça et là le truc c'est
qu'on a des vérités qui sont résistantes
mais en fait c'est des vérités qui sont
très diverses génétiquement hockey et
donc du coup dans le tas on a plein de
plein d'individus qui ne sont pas
résistants l'accueil du coup ça on a
tout de même des pertes
ok donc ça serait avancée sélectionner
les variétés
parmi celles qui existent déjà qui sont
les plus résistants c'est ouais enfin
enfin du coup vu qu'on a déjà des
vérités qui sont résistantes
c'est l'idée c'est plus de deux puissent
cibler le gêne
jane précisément dans le processus de
sélection pour ne pas avoir ces
individus dans le tas qui qui n'ont pas
qu'ils n'ont pas ce jeune là qui nous
passe est allé au delà de résistance
brett très bien et donc apparemment a
donc été d'actualité maintenant de
recherche
tu t'es lancé sur youtube et twitter
comment tu t'es lancé
donc ben ça pendant au masters j'ai
quand même aussi eu ma licence un peu g
comment dire j'ai beaucoup remis en
question pas mal de croyance que j'avais
peur qu'en gt gt anti ogm je mangeais
bio j'étais anti pesticides et ougrée me
connaissant je pense que c'est quelque
chose de surprenant
j'étais avec ces idées là je conseille
monsanto c'est l'idéal macha et de coude
en étant dans ce parcours de biologie
particulier sur les plans de la
génétique tout je me suis rendu compte
que que c'est pas exactement ce que je
pensais et plus plus lisez plus je me
renseigne et plus j'avais deux courts
dessus et que je me rendais compte que
en fait c c'est non seulement c'est pas
si mauvais que ce qu'on entend mais en
plus ça peut être aussi vachement
bénéfiques comme disait la joie si j'ai
une vérité qui est résistante
ça permet de diminuer les quantités
pesticides ça permet d'avoir moins de
pertes c'est donc ça peut être aussi
vachement vachement intéressant quoi
ouais et du coup c'est quelque chose en
vulgarisation que que je voyais assez
peu quoi
les sujets de biologie à dirty
biologique en a fait un peu qui fait un
clin je veux dire qu'un peu parlé des
ogm où il a fait une vidéo où il en
parle mais c'est plus un prétexte je
crois pour pour parler de la sphère
céréales signé du traitement médiatique
et de comment une information
scientifique est raide et il le sujet
c'est les ogm mais il parle pas vraiment
des ogm et donc du coup je me suis dit
ce serait peut-être intéressant de d'en
parler justement de faire une petite
synthèse sur ces sujets et de forcer sa
de mettre des études de 2,2 de proposer
voilà quelque chose pour que les gens
puissent se renseigner par eux-mêmes là
dessus avec des études etc
à la base a la base je pensais pas du
tout que ça que ça prendrait cette
ampleur c'était plus un truc pour
envoyer à mes potes à ma famille qu'ils
aient voilà qui ce genre de ressource là
mais et du coup ça a pris un peu une
petite ampleur du coup ouais c'est cool
et du coup il goûtait ta ta ta changer
d'avis un petit peu sur tout ça on prend
quand en lissant suivante est quoi ce
que c'était le cas de d autres personnes
dans ta classe je sais pas trop non il y
en a certains qui sont plus ce qu'ils
étaient dans mon master avec moi qui
étais aussi etc étaient toujours qu'ils
sont toujours d'ailleurs je pense très
très anti ogm et où malgré malgré ce que
je leur dis ce que d'autres personnes
dans mon master qui étaient avec nous
dit
lisez aussi ne s'était pas si facile et
pas uniquement les cours qui t'ont fait
changer d'avis yeux non je pense pas non
stevie aussi en lisant ouais je sais pas
si c'est vraiment lié mais c'est aussi à
ce moment là que j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser plus au scepticisme avec
avec les chaînes comme la tronche en
biais ou jade mental ou plus questionné
épluché rentrée voilà plus aussi dense
et se faire un peu sceptique ou oudin
dans ces sphères là c'est on est on est
on a plus tendance à être projet m haies
et ce genre de choses et éduquer c'est
ce qu'évoque du mois précédent si on ne
plus réfléchir plus sérieusement à ces
questions que tu as changé d'avis mais
les autres ont pas fait cet effort coup
quand est-ce qu'on peut amener les
autres c'est une très bonne question est
celle qui malheureusement parce que
ouais si je serai pas comment aborder la
question au plus fort puisque je pense
qu'il faudrait il faut vraiment être
dans dé bonnes dispositions faut être
faut vouloir changer d'avis enfin il
faut que faut être ouvert aux faits
dir est-ce que je peux changer d'avis
quoi et il ya certaines personnes qui
qui n'en sont pas capables et que faim
qu'ils ne le veulent pas ou je ne sais
pas après je dis pas que moi je me
refais je suis ouvert et tout je suis
capable de changer d'avis et je sais que
fin je pense que tout le monde est un
peu comme ça on a nos opinions et c'est
pas forcément facile de changer d'avis
la lada non pas sur eux sur le cas des
ogm en particulier ce qu'il ya eu un
déclic en partie des ou si c'était un
peu précis où tu t'es dit ross s'est pas
si mal oui c'était un peu un peu
progressif mais moi je me souviens j'ai
eu j'ai eu un exposé à faire dans une
matière qui se s'étaient sur les risques
environnementaux et donc j'avais une
petite partie sur les ogm ou la prof et
ai été très bien donc c'est une des
preuves qui m'a fait un peu changé
d'avis et donc du coup la plupart des
sujets n'étaient pas sur les nobles mc
déçu jean réchauffement climatique
pollution etc
il y avait 2 3 2 3 et u2 sur les ogm et
je me suis dit je vais je vais prendre
ce sujet là il a cité une étude eu une
étude sur plusieurs années en chine qui
montrait que que depuis l'adoption du
coton bt ou qui est un coton résistant
aux insectes et il y avait des impacts
bénéfiques de ces ogm d'un côté parce
que qui permettent de contrôler
efficacement les herbivores les
ravageurs et de l'autre côté ça permet
du coup d' éviter d'utiliser infecté
side et vu qu'on évite d'utiliser les
insecticides du coup il ya moins
d'impact sur les autres insectes et en
plus ces autres un siècle à ben il y en
a dans le tas qui sont des prédateurs de
ce qui va bouffer les plans donc on a un
deuxième effet positif
ouais et du coup c'est voilà ce genre ce
genre d'étude à holmby hills et c'est ça
peut avoir un impact assez assez
considérable quoi peut-être que c'est
peut-être lié à la prise de recul sur la
complexité du problème
peut-être je suis pas et du coup tu t'es
là c'est d'abord sur twitter aussi
ben j'avais mon compte twitter mais je
ne faisais pas de vulgarisation de
succès vraiment youtube et d'écouté
d'ailleurs jacques en inde a vivement tt
vidéo sur youtube pour ceux qui écoutent
ccc beaucoup d'informations qui est
modifié à trouver ailleurs je vois
quelques questions à petit parce que tu
connais d'autres sources comme ça qui
parle de ses problèmes qui sont
abordables des sources
ça dépend de quel quel genre de quel
genre de deux sources ont fait un jeu
que je connais des gens qui font de la
vulgarisation mais c'est quand c'est
silencieux c'est plus un sujet très
précis et quoi ces genres
le glyphosate
par rapport à telle télé fait du
glyphosate par rapport à une étude de ce
genre de choses sur moi j'essaie à faire
j'essaye de faire un truc plus de
synthèse une vision un peu globale et
qui veut pas non plus exhaustive mais
certaines ouais ouais c'est vrai qu'il
me semble assez déficience je pense que
pas d effort de synthèse et de cesse de
base de méta analyse quoi finalement de
de pas mal de choses qui ont été publiés
c'est que tu as des frictions à ces
définitions mais je pense que je pense
que mario n'a quand même de plus en plus
j'ai l'impression que je ne sais pas si
c'est parce que je suis de plus en plus
compliqué dans dans le milieu mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il est un peu plus avec
le temps j'ai passé que l'impression
parce que du coup on peut parler un peu
plus les entend pas parler un peu du
glyphosate et de ce qui s'est passé
récemment à ce que tu pas visés par
l'impact s'est passé récemment autour
des qui faisait la force heures de cloud
je sais pas quoi dire à part notamment
le documentaire à partir des denrées
spéciale de deux voyages janvier donc
plus d'amis envoyé spécial sur le
glyphosate way est donc alors déjà de
base il y avait eu une des articles qui
qui annonçait qui va et qui allait la
voie qui allait avoir cette cette
émission avec il présentait déjà les
axes qui allaient être abordées donc du
coup il ya plusieurs personnes dont moi
qui qui on s'est dit bon ok ça peut être
n'importe quoi parce que ces jeux les
axes qui a qui étaient présentes et
c'est le genre de on s'attendait à les
aider des présentations auxquelles on a
l'habitude qui seront sont toujours les
mêmes et gâche à fond à chaque fois
qu'on lirait plus les réfute
elles reviennent gré et donc du coup ça
des cdd des choses auxquelles on a déjà
une contre argumentation du coup on a
essayé de construire un peu contre
argumentation à ça de faire un live
tweet en direct pour réfuter en direct
tout ce qui est toutes les conneries
caté dit
après il ya des choses qui étaient
fallait pas tout était faux enfin des
choses qui étaient fausses
il y avait eu projet utopia aussi
qu'avait fait ac avait fait lui il avait
fait des prédictions avance avant
l'émission et le chien ne pas mettre les
tris à tomber je sais du coup et ouais
donc et donc du coup on a apporté plein
de critiques après on a essayé de
remettre ça un petit peu en forme il ya
eu plusieurs frais il ya huit mois il y
avait plein coeur des il ya eu donc
projet utopia aussi un mondrian
principalement je crois que c'est tout
après il y en a eu d'autres qui sont
venus aussi plus à posteriori ouais et
suite à ça il ya une ouvrière y est
aussi d'autres au niveau 2 des
journalistes aussi a eu à gérer de
nouveaux senneurs emmanuel du croquis
sont donc des journalistes qui en ce
moment du coup soit un petit peu
dénigrer justement parce qu'elles
prennent elles prennent parti contre
envoyé spécial contre liste du csr et
bref donc du coup suite à ça il ya
france télévisions et j'en ai les three
lions qui ont donné une réponse qui ont
fait un article reprenant point par
point les critiques qui leur étaient
faites donc déjà déjà je me souviens pas
mais il me semble que les jeunes n'ont
pas pris de l'ensemble des critiques qui
leur étaient faites et quand on regarde
les réponses qu'ils ont fait aux
critiques il y en a qui sont qu'ils sont
vrais et par exemple il ya eu un
argument que j'ai utilisé donc dans le
reportage ils vont au sri-lanka et ils
disent que le sri lanka interdit
glyphosate est en fait le sri lanka
réautoriser glyphosate il ya maintenant
un an un an et demi est en fait il
aurait autorisé que pour le thé et le
caoutchouc et moi dans les infos que
j'avais et j'avais l'info qu'il a été
réautorisée pour toutes les cultures et
en fait c'est juste que je n'avais pas
eu toute la formation c'est que en fait
tu parles en fait il ya bien eu cette
autorisation mais en fait la personne
qu'il a fait n'avait pas les compétences
pour le faire du coup il ya eu tout un
micmac est en fait finalement ccvc bel
et bien que pour le thé et le caoutchouc
ok donc du coup là du coup pour le coup
là j'ai dit quelque chose qui était faux
et du coup ben voila quand on envoyé
spécial a dit non c'est pas vrai c'est
vraiment ça que pour le coton le
caoutchouc et le thé j'ai fait venir à
table
oui sur cet argument là j'avais tort
mais après après il ya d'autres
arguments où il y répond de manière
parcellaire où ils répondent pas du tout
ou alors ils répondent des choses qui
sont encore plus faux et là encore du
coup il y à la théière cosmique qui a
qui a un petit peu concon ans et où
toutes les réponses aux réponses qu'on
avait fait du coup sa vie
ces réponses et qui a fait un super
article que vous pouvez aller voir ses
rivaux à l escalade envoyé spécial
d'escaladé je sais plus quoi dire
cosmique dont je pense que vous le
trouverez mai et du qooq est très bien
qu'il résume un peu tout et toute la
sphère et est depuis depuis les
journalistes se répondent plus du tout
aux critiques et ils sont ils sont se
sont lancés dans une sorte de croisade
contre les les trolls de monsanto des
cons des condos de défendre un peu
glyphosate c'est parce qu'on est payé
par monsanto on est des lobbyistes qu'on
ait des trolls donc c'est c'est
insultant c'est limite de la diffamation
c'est fin c'est là c'est affolant que
des journalistes et des journalistes du
service celui de quoi de france trans de
quoi qui ont recours à ce genre de chose
quoi et parce que je pose un bagage ans
il y avait deux à avoir des crédits est
ce qu a eu des trolls de monsanto qui
vous participez à la discussion
bah c'est très bien que tu mentionnes ça
parce que du coup il ya eu 1 une autre
personne dont que la chèvre pensante qui
a repris un peu ses accusations de il ya
des trolls et tout c'était la directrice
des programmes de france télévisions de
weylandt qui avait dit qu'il était
harcelé qu' il y avait plein de petits
contes qui venait juste d'être créée
avec peu d'abonnés qui étaient
insultants et qui arrêtait pas leur
envoyer des messages tirés et donc du
coup la chèvre pensante a fait une
synthèse de tous les tweets qui
répondait à envoyé spécial
spécifiquement sur sur cette émission là
et qui a analysé les tweets un parent en
regardant les comptes combien d'abonnés
ils ont depuis quand le compte a été
créé le contenu du tweet est ce que le
tweet est insultant agressif
est-ce qu'il est plutôt pro ou anti et c
est ce qui ressort de la synthèse c'est
que ben ce genre de compte il y en a
mais c'est une minorité
et il y en a des deux côtés en fait il
ya aussi ce genre de comptes dans les
pros promos spéciales ceux qui défendent
en vol spécial il y en a obligé des
comptes qui sont insultants qu'on peu
d'abonnés et ccc épilation là elles sont
elles sont un peu bancal hockey est
d'aider des trolls des deux côtés ici
pas forcément les personnes les plus
influentes était à côté
oui voilà et surtout fins et c'est un
peu le joker quoi c'est utilisé comme un
commun voilà comme un joker pour ne pas
avoir à répondre aux critiques c'est
qu'on va vous êtes payés par les lobbys
ou vous êtes un troll dont je réponds
pas aux critiques
quand bien même les critiques seraient
fondées je ne serai pas très très bien
des médias et en particulier face mais
du coup ça faisait quand même pas mal de
temps que les médias mainstream on va
dire a été très critique du glyphosate
non oui ça fait un moment que tous les
gros médias étaient à critiquer le
glyphosate
la plupart des gros médias
le monde principalement il ya loeb c'est
aussi loeb ski qui avait publié donc
l'étude de ces lignes il y avait bien un
artiste rey s'est réuni après son étude
bref le seul journal
c'est peut-être pas le seul mais le
disons un des gros qui est qui est plus
ce qu appliquer plus critique sur ces
sujets là c'est le figaro où la f3 qui
hier ou avant-hier il ya eu un nouvel
article est sorti qui disait que le
glyphosate c'est un faux problème de
santé publique et qui qui qui remet
peut-être un peu un peu plus en
perspective
et c'est c'est un des rares à des rares
journaux qui qui qui fait que je
travaille un peu un peu plus critique
quoi disons un peu moins accusateur est
un peu moins ces longs santos et les
lobbys c'est la manipulation
ouais et démocrates explique que que
quasiment tous les journaux et par les
grands médias français ce soit me
contrefiche de glyphosate
je sais pas je sais pas après après ça
va je veux pas être dans le complot
tison disons qu'il ya des acteurs
derrière aussi peut-être qu'il y en a
mais en vrai pas savoir et j'ai pas de
quoi pour le dire et c'est pas un super
but non plus ne veut dire que c'est
parce qu'il ya des lobby derrière aussi
c'est logique c'est le genre d'argument
que je critique et de ce côté là mais
après après je pense qu'il ya un gros
problème au niveau médiatique au niveau
de la science quoi l aij et les
journalistes scientifiques n'ont pour la
plupart par des centres de formation
scientifique assez des journalistes
quand une formation de juriste
ils n'ont pas forcément formés à la
méthode scientifique et comment est
construite une étude comment se
construit un consensus
l'épistémologie des choses comme ça
c'est carrément un problème mais bahreïn
est ce que moi j'ai l'impression aussi
que ce mouvement contre le glyphosate
est très liée à des mouvements écolos
oui oui oui donc l'annoncé des années
mon mouvement environnementaux aux
antilles par anti ogm anti-pesticides
quoi et le glyphosate en fait c'est un
peu c'est un peu l'épouvantail quoi
c'est parce que c'est le produit le plus
utilisé dans le monde s'est produit le
plus vendu parce que c'est monsanto
aussi donc c'est un peu la cible facile
aussi
ouais et puis je vais gilles yau
santeuil a failli et pas mal d amalgame
hauteur surtout oui oui et surtout fin
monsanto on pourrait enfin on dit que je
suis payé par deux sont thomas chamon ce
retour devrait enfin ils ont fait des
manoeuvres qui sont largement
critiquable qua non que maintenant que
le public fasse a fait de cette
association là c'est pas non plus
surprenant et tu peux parler un pad et
pourquoi est ce que l'on sera très
critiquable bas par exemple quand il ya
eu la monographie du crc donc le centre
international de recherche sur le cancer
qui a publié sept sera port disant que
le glyphosate était cancérigène probable
est donc monsanto a aimé a pas beaucoup
aimé et ça c'est quelque chose qui
ressort c'est donc avec les monsanto
papers où on voit que dans leur mail
ils disent ici cesser de faire de la com
en s'attaquant au crc plutôt qu'au fond
en essayant de décrédibiliser le crc
notamment et me semblant en essayant
d'engager un ancien du crc pour lui
faire dire du mal du crc donc c'est
vraiment des balais technique aux
commentaires après ça veut pas dire que
le glyphosate est cancérigène qua non a
donc du courage par les critiques du
camp c'est du glyphosate est souvent qui
est cancérigène price c'est quoi la
critique classique du glyphosate
c'est difficile parce que là là
généralement oui c'est le glyphosate est
cancérigène mais après on explique que
le glyphosate est pas cancérigène alors
du coup ça devient oui mais alors il est
perturbateur endocrinien
donc on dit maintenant regarder des
études qui montrent qu'il n'est pas
perturbateurs rien du coup c'est oui
mais alors du coup et des impacts sur
l'environnement
mais du coup on explique que oui il ya
des risques pour l'environnement mais
ces risques ont les minimise par exemple
et des risques qui sont identifiés pour
les organismes aquatiques et du coup
l'utilisation de glyphosate près de près
de point d'eau est interdite hier et que
ensuite le glyphosate peut aussi être
bénéfique pour l'environnement en
favorisant des pratiques notamment de
non travail du sol qui vont favoriser
cette vie du sol donc être bénéfique
pour le sol et est du coup enfin à
chaque fois qu'on essaie de répondre à
un argument il n'a toujours rien
derrière
et puisqu'on n'a pas répondu à cette
question alors du coup il faut appliquer
le principe de précaution on a pas on
n'a pas prouvé que le glyphosate de
costa l'otiv que ça cause pas j'ai pas
moins le sida donc comme on l'a pas
trouvé ça eh bien il faut appliquer le
principe de précaution
sauf que enfin c'est c'est un peu c'est
excessif quoi on peut pas on peut pas
prouver tout ça on peut pas déjà on peut
pas prouver l'absence de quelque chose
c'est difficile on peut pas le prouver
l'absence d'un effet mais du coup enfin
on peut pas non plus se permettre de ne
pas autoriser un produit ce contexte
qu'on n'a pas tout
tout regarder parce que parce que c'est
des produits nous aussi que dont les
agriculteurs ont besoin quoi ouais
quelles que soient les conséquences
écologiques d'interdire du flood votre
paquet que là le problème c'est que il
faut des alternatifs faut qu'on ait
quelque chose de viable à côté et le
glyphosate
c'est ce jour quasiment la seule
technique ou le célèbre outil qui soit
vraiment efficace pour lutter contre pas
mal pas mal de mauvaises herbes à mal
d'adventices rien et les seules
alternatives qu'on aurait si on rdr il
faut si on interdisait le glyphosate
ce serait déjà d'autres herbicides donc
en place un art visite par un autre
habitude c'est clairement pas l'idéal
surtout que ça choque le glyphosate et
l'herbicide de moins toxiques et ça veut
dire que les autres ambitions plus
toxiques
c'est aussi du coup il ya d'autres
techniques de travail du sol le travail
mécanique donc le lab où on va retourner
le sol etc
ça ça pose d'autres problèmes parce que
ça va ça va perturber les organismes qui
sont dans le sol que ce qu'on va faire
des trous dans le sang on va retourner
la terre et où il ya les organismes qui
sont profonds et qui vivent là où il ya
pas d'oxygène qui vont être remontés là
où il ya de l'oxygène et vice versa les
autres qui ont besoin d'oxygène ils vont
être enfouis et donc s'aperçurent vcet
perd sur toute sa vie du sol et c c'est
pas bon du tout pour pour la vie pour la
structure du sol aussi ça favorise
l'érosion
mais quand il ya des pluies ben il ya
des lieux de la terre qui part dans les
pluies et du coup un petit à petit on
perd on perd de la terre en fête hier
et voilà tout ça c'est des impacts que
l'interdiction du glyphosate aura c'est
probablement après il ya des des
alternatives qui sont viables mais c'est
que dans des cas particuliers dans
certaines régions
on sur certaines cultures sur certains
sur certaines mauvaises herbes et c'est
des choses qui sont pas généralisables
et ce genre de technique là les
agriculteurs les utilisent déjà pour la
plupart il y en a beaucoup qui utilisent
ce genre de technique parce qu'ils sont
aussi conscients de ces problèmes des
agriculteurs tout cas interdire le
glyphosate pour avoir des conséquences
c'est ça ou on pense on pense que le
glyphosate posent certains risques donc
il faut l'interdire mais on pense pas à
ce que ça les conséquences que ça vrai
quoi on voit un peu à court terme quoi
et est du coup parce que tu allais dire
un double intérêt dit que tu étais
opposé tâche médaille chaud sur le bio
qui explique un peu pourquoi
ouais bah le bio ça peut compliquer
voire un le bio en gros déjà il ya
beaucoup d'idées reçues quoi le bio
c'est déjà s'est basé sur sur un
sophisme d'appel à la nature c'est on va
utiliser des choses qui sont naturels y
sauf que nature et ça veut rien dire ça
va pas dire que c'est meilleur et donc
donc du coup s'est basée sur quelque
chose qui est un peu bancal à la base et
ensuite ça va être ça va être là c'est
donc sur une interdiction de tout ce qui
est synthèse donc pesticides et
fertilisants principalement et de tout
ce qui est ogm mais donc du coup il ya
des idées reçues sur le fait que bas
comme on dit on interdit les pesticides
de synthèse 9e on se dit le bio
n'utilise pas de pesticides mais sauf
que le bio utilise des pesticides est
juste que c'est les pesticides qui sont
naturels donc on n'a pas donc le cuivre
qui est un métal qui qui peut
s'accumuler qui s'accumulent dans les
sols donc le l'utilisation est régulée
parce que justement on sait qu'il ya des
problèmes on régule on en utilise une
certaine quantité mais quand même forcé
un métal qui s'accumulent donc ça pose
quand même des problèmes contient et et
c'est pas parce que c'est naturel que
c'est mieux quoi parce que ça pose aussi
des problèmes au lieu de chercher un
produit qui est meilleur peu importe son
origine
on va chercher un produit qui est
naturel peu importe si les meilleurs ou
pas donc c'est un peu contre productif
après il ya aussi le principal impact du
bio c'est que du coup vu qu'on a on a on
a interdit les pesticides de synthèse on
a moins de pesticides et on a aussi des
pesticides qui sont pas forcément pas
forcément efficace qu'on est ici d'un
peu moins efficace donc du coup ça ça
pose aussi des problèmes au niveau du
rendement parce que vu que ya moins de
moyens de contrôler les ravageurs
pathogènes on va voir plus de pertes et
en moyenne le bio il a en moyenne ça
c'est ça varie selon les cultures même
moyenne ces 20% du rendement donc 20% de
rendre moins moi ça veut dire que en fin
le rendant enfin il faut il faut nourrir
le monde quoi donc il faut qu'on ait une
certaine production pour pouvoir nous
étonnons et si on à moindre rendement
mais il faut bien trouver d'autres
moyens de produire et les barras le seul
autre moine polir c'est de produire sur
plus de surface produire moins mais sur
plus de surface donc du coup avoir
besoin de plus de surface ça veut dire
que ces surfaces il faut lire o te faut
les trouver quelque part comme il faut
il faut déforester il faut détruire des
habitats naturels et ça c'est un impact
qui est assez important sur la
biodiversité sur environnants pourquoi
raser plus des terrains de forêts
notamment
c'est pas très écolo mais qu'est ce que
c'est que c'est une conséquence un peu
indirecte du coup peut-être que les gens
s
oui ça c'est quelque chose que l'on ne
voit pas ne voit pas parce que pareille
pareil comme le polo y va quand on
interdit il ya des conséquences derrière
auquel on pense pas mais là aussi il ya
des conséquences bien on voit pas
forcément
et le truc c'est que le bio il ya des
très belles choses en bio il ya pas mal
d'études qui montrent que au niveau
local vu que ça utilise moins de
pesticides
c'est sûr que ça aura un impact un peu
positifs sur sur la biodiversité sur
l'environnement alentour
mais du coup quand on réfléchit en plus
grande échelle du coût en terme global
vue qui a ses problèmes de rendement et
où est ben ça pose pas forcément moins
problème c'est peut-être même plus de
problèmes que que le conventionnel
malgré des effets un peu bénéfique
localement mais cirque si on regarde la
même
même champ et il est entouré médias du
champ où on peut avoir l'impression que
ça améliore la diversité mais si on
regarde sur l'échelle tension ailleurs
que à cause de la déforestation de
peut-être d'autres phénomènes en fait
globalement ça ça peut être néfaste
c'est ça du coup assez sa difficulté de
d'année les gens à ne pas interpréter
leur environnement immédiat comme étant
quelque chose de représentatif d'un
phénomène plus globale ce qui n'est
jamais facile à faire
non et donc au site est doté est
positionné en faveur des ogm en
particulier en particulier magie de la
recherche que j'aime ou quelque chose
comme ça je pense qu'assez de recherche
sur les ogm pas nouveau clairement non
parce que la recherche allait carrément
freiné parce que ça il n'y a pas
d'intérêt à faire la recherche sur les
ogm parce que en mieux les ogm ils sont
morts quoi cultiver des ogm
à part les agriculteurs parce que ils
auraient des intérêts parce que ça leur
ferait plus de rendement vraiment le
pesticide à utiliser mais au niveau du
public le public ne peut pas d'objets m
donc c'est très difficile quand enfin
qu'est ce que ça pourrait apporter que
d'ouvrir un peu plus la porte à la
recherche sur les ogm
ben le truc des ogm en ce moment c'est
que il ya que deux grandes catégories
d'hô gm qui sont cultivées pour dans la
majorité c'est les ogm résistants au
glyphosate et les ogm bt donc qu'ils
sont
résistant aux insectes way est en fait
il n'ya pas que ce à quoi il ya un
potentiel énorme parce que c'est juste
rajouter un gène ou modifier un gène et
et on a une vérité qui qui par exemple
je pas un miro rien que ça qui peut voir
des meilleures qualités nutritionnelles
ont peu à voir j'ai pas du blé sans
gluten on peut avoir des variétés qui
sont enrichis en vitamines et les choses
comme ça on va voir du coup voilà des
variétés résistantes aux ravageurs qui
permet du coup d'éviter - pesticides on
peut avoir tout un tas de choses quand
il ya vraiment énormément de
possibilités a eu le fait que que des
paquets que la recherche là dessus soit
freinée ça empêche toute cette
innovation qui pourrait être bénéfique
autant pour les agriculteurs pour les
consommateurs aussi pour l'environnement
pour tout un tas chose est ce que la
plupart des gauchistes serait en faveur
de beaucoup plus de recherches sur les
ogm aux biologistes tu veux dire dans
quels domaines déjà d'un descendant au
niveau des plantes peut-être les
biologistes jeu honnêtement je ne sais
pas je ne sais pas du tout quel est le
la tendance au niveau des chercheurs
là-dedans d'expériences personnelles je
sais que j'ai un travail à l'inra j'ai
été en contact avec des gens qui étaient
très opposés à ce alors ça avec des
chercheurs et ça m'a un peu un peu
choqué mais je sais qu'il ya des
personnes avec qui sont un peu opposés à
ça et sur des bases qui sont mal du coup
pas forcément très très solide et donc
il ya des débats qui ont lieu entre
entre les chercheurs ces questions ne
sais pas si tu pense qu'il faudrait
qu'il y avoir de discussion d'organiser
genre si on pouvait voir consensus des
biologistes sur cette question sera
beaucoup plus facile de
inspirera qu sa confiance
oui c'est sûr mais est en fait le truc
c'est que je sais pas exactement la
tendance au niveau global au niveau des
chercheurs quoi je sais qu'il ya eu un
sondage sur les chercheurs de la hesse
qui est la société américaine je crois
que c'est ce qui est publié au seuil ans
et donc ces chercheurs la sueur dans
séché dans ce panel de chercheurs là
c'était 80 % qui était en faveur des ogm
il me semble tous comme ça ok mais je
pense que du coup ça dépend du panel
quoi ça dépend du pays aussi ça ne
compte pas de pas mal de choses
un duo enfin de l'europe et
particulièrement l'europe et waimes
particulièrement opposés à sa vie et du
coup dans les autres pays a besoin de
beaucoup plus de gens qui sont en
travers de la recherche a ajouté m / je
connais pas exactement
ce qui se dit sur ça mais aux états unis
enfin en amérique en général il ya quand
même beaucoup plus de choses qui sont
dans ce domaine là il ya déjà déjà il ya
beaucoup plus de culture qui qui qui
varie plus beaucoup plus d'objets qui
sont cultivés en amérique et en dans
l'union européenne c'est que que une
variété de maillé ce qui est cultivé en
espagne dans quelques sur quelques
hectares et dans deux trois pays où
c'est vraiment anecdotique quand ray est
ce qu'il y ait des recherches qu'il
essayait des technologies comme chris
peur ben là aussi c'est aussi cette
différence entre l'europe et le reste du
monde parce que lui il ya eu cette
clarification de la cour de justice de
l'union européenne en juillet dernier où
il y avait il y avait un espèce de flou
juridique sur la dénomination ogm sur ce
qu'était la mutagénèse est-ce que la
méta jeunesse était considéré comme ogm
pas prêt et là c'est jules à ses yeux la
cour de justice a tranché en disant que
oui la mutagénèse est considéré comme
ogm et les nouvelles techniques de 2,2
de mutagénèse donc comme chrysler
devrait être régulée comme comme des ogm
ou du coup là ça apporte un frein
supplémentaire encore à la recherche un
e chef sur sur l'amélioration sur le
développement de nouvelles variétés et
c'est encore plus
difficile parce que bassett se fera là
il n'est pas forcément là dans d'autres
pays il ya deux pays qui du coup
pourront être plus compétitifs nous ça
pose aussi comme pas le problème je vais
expliquer un peu ce qu'est la mutagénèse
alors la mutagénèse en gros c'est qu'on
génère des mutations dans le génome
donc j'ai vu les gènes c'est ces quatre
cd succession de quatre nucléotides donc
qu'on représente par des lettres à ctv
et donc leur succession c'est un peu la
recette de cuisine de de tout notre
corps on a toutes les instructions pour
faire toutes les protéines dans notre
corps qui servent à à notre
fonctionnement quand même en très gros
et donc du coup du coup dans ce gîte
dans ce jeune homme il ya constamment
des mutations parce que on est exposé à
lézat lambda gm comme les radiations par
exemple les uv donc ça ça génère des
mutations mais il ya aussi les cellules
quand elle se tait se multiplient elle
recopie l'adn et des fois ils recopient
pas exactement
donc on a des par exemple un acquis
devient un sais je sais pas à des
changements comme ça et ça c'est des
changements qui sont naturels et on la
mutagenèse c'est faire ces mêmes
changements mais en les forçant un peu
donc en utilisant des agents mutagènes
comme des radiations des des agents
chimiques qui vont du coup modifier la
séquence génétique ou alors du coup en
bas là on a les nouvelles techniques de
de mutagénèse comme chris peur si qui
vont cibler une région précise et
induire une limitation à cet endroit
précis alors que les radiations et les
agents chimiques ça induit des mutations
un peu aléatoire manger nous on appelle
ça du coup la mutagénèse aléatoire alors
crise peur c'est plus de la médaille
jeunesse ciblées et après si on avait
ciblé si beaucoup ne puissent commencer
oui le corps puisse continuer parce que
la mutagénèse à l'abattoir en fait on
comme c'est aléatoire on veut être sûr
que une mutation dans notre chaîne qui
nous intéresse nous avons fait plein de
mutation partout pour être sûr qu'il y
en ait au moins une dame on le veut du
coup la des mutations partout et pour
pour se débarrasser six mutations ont
refait des croisements avec des plans
qui sont pas muté en s'assurant que la
mutation d'intérêt elle déçoit elles
soient restés mais on se débarrasse pas
de toutes les mutations qu en fait
en fait il ya beaucoup plus de
modifications du swing et il s'est
crispé du coup les critiques récurrentes
imagine de ce genre de freud eu de
problème c'est le principe de précaution
qu'est ce que tu dis ce que tu penses du
principe de précaution
je pense que le principe d'une pression
c'est une bonne chose mais il faut pas
l'utiliser à outrance principe de
précaution il est appliqué pour pour les
pesticides et pour les ogm c'est à dire
que pour qu'il soit mis sur le marché on
demande aux entreprises qui veulent les
commercialiser de fournir des études de
faire des études de toxicologie et d
étude de cancérogénicité des études sur
l'impact environnemental tout un terrain
d'étude pour prouver que ben oui notre
ville et les pires sans risque donc du
coup on applique bien pour le principe
de précaution comme
demande des études avant être pour être
sûrs avant d'autoriser quoi et ironie
pense ça c'est quelque chose qui fait
que pour les ogm parce qu'ils doivent
être régulés alors que les autres
variétés bas elles doivent pas subir ce
genre de test et donc c'est un peu
ironique haut du col et les autres
espèces
tu parles des trucs ce serait quand même
autre espèce ces trucs déjà implanté
c'est tout bah non c'est tout c'est
toutes les variétés obtenues par des
techniques dites un peu classique donc
la mutagénèse aléatoire ll c'est quelque
chose de classique c'est que jusqu'en
utilisent depuis des années 1930
ok c'est quelque chose d'assez vieux
c'est quelque chose qui est considéré
comme un classique aujourd'hui etc est
pourquoi après il ya d'autres techniques
comme des hybridations entre différentes
différentes variétés il ya aussi des
techniques un peu plus cellulaires ont
fait aussi la delà de la culture in
vitro des choses comme ça c'est des
techniques aussi de laboratoires mais
qui sont considérés comme classiques
comme pas où j'aime ce que du coup à la
mutagénèse aléatoire c'est à moi de
faire plein de situations un peu d
unification non contrôlés on va dire et
ça ça subir est beaucoup moins de tests
qu'un truc qui passerait par qu'elle se
crispe heures c'est ça et c'est pas
considérer enfin c'est con parce que
c'est compliqué parce que en fait c'est
considéré comme gm mais ils sont exempts
de régulation donc c'est un peu un peu
complexe ok il est technique par
l'hybridation à quel point ça va être
dangereux
ben on globalement la plupart des
variétés que tu manges cdi droid d
innover que ce soit des trucs qui sont
hybridés ya des milliers d'années genre
tous les agrumes c'est la plupart cédés
hybride qui viennent de deux ou trois
variétés de trois espèces ancestrales et
ça il ya eu plein d'hybridation entre
ces trois espèces entre les îles avec
des hybrides et chose comme ça pour
donner tous les avions aujourd'hui mais
tout ça c'est des ibériques ont dit
inter spécifique donc entre espèces est
prié les hybrides intraspécifique dont à
l'intérieur de l'espèce et ça c'est des
hybrides entre différentes variétés par
exemple
arrêté qu elles résistantes et un
pathogène et j'ai une variété qui et qui
donne des gros fruits je vais les
croisés entre eux et j'aurai un hybride
qui sera à la fois résistant est à la
fois avec des gros fruits et puis il ya
aussi un phénomène qu'on appelle la
vigueur hybride qui fait que les les
hybrides sont de manière générale plus
vigoureux plus performants que les deux
parents même que la somme de leurs
performances ou quelque chose comme ça
c'est vraiment un effet rock n ya pas
mal à gagner à faire cesser un percevoir
des opérations hockey et depuis toute
faute à personne quand est-ce que tu
t'informe quand est-ce que tu réfléchis
à tous et tous ces sujets ce n'est pas
quelque chose avait des gens sur twitter
des chercheurs des des études
scientifiques je me renseigne un peu de
poisson c'est bon domaine donc je tombe
assez facilement sur ce genre de public
via via les chercheurs avec qui je
travaille et tous les gens avec qui il
communique
après oui après je pense que c'est avant
tout mais je reviens un peu sur ce
principe de précaution oui parce que
aille à paris un truc moi je fais un peu
mon bail en mai sur un an contre la
mutagénèse
aléatoire une tajine est plus ciblée a
priori comment 25,4 en cas de crise peur
on s'est vraiment que la modification
fait du coup il ya beaucoup moins
d'incertitudes quant à priori il ya
beaucoup moins de risque puisqu'on ya
beaucoup d'incertitudes
du coup ils devraient avoir a priori sur
madame façon comme ça un niveau
d'exigence sur les tests qui suis-je
différent plus faibles lorsqu'on sait ce
qu'on fait quand même moindre tu voulais
moindre propos christophe oui après
après y'a pas non plus n'est pas non
plus impossible qu'il y ait des effets
non qu'on pouvait pas prévoir crise peur
par exemple il ya pas mal de ce qu'on
appelle des offres target c'est à dire
que ça va ça va aller sur des cargaisons
des cibles frentzen sur sur quelque
chose qu'on n'a pas ciblé en fait ça va
modifier des parties de juno qu'on n'a
pas qu'on voulait pas ciblé et ça c'est
quelque chose qui est assez
problématique en biologie animale quand
on veut faire de la thérapie génique
quelque chose comme ça en biologie
végétale bon c'est des trucs qu'on va
manger et ce n'est pas non plus ultra
problématique
après ça peut poser des problèmes de
problème justement toxiques d'allergies
ça peut arriver
par contre j'ai en est l'exemple d'une
recette c'est pas crise peur mais c'est
la transgénèse mais c'était une variété
de poids il me semble qui a été
développé on a rajouté u11 gène codant
pour une protéine je sais plus
exactement ce qu'elle faisait la variété
à laquelle on a rajouté ce gène n'était
pas allergènes le jus la protéine
n'était pas les rejets mais la variété
avec le
elle devenir les rejets et justement par
rapport à ce principe de précaution à
ces tests qui sont exigées ça a été
détectée avant en un an de
l'autorisation et donc du coup on a
abandonné toute recherche sur cette
vérité là il avait arrêté n'a pas été
commercialisée il reste plein de choses
il reste une énorme incertitude
parce que le vivant c'est compliqué je
la déteste après mais après après faire
des tests c'est une bonne chose
s'assurer qu'il n'y ait pas de problèmes
de toxicité et c'est très bien mais
c'est assez c'est comment dire c'est un
peu bizarre de d'exiger sa que des ogm
et pas des autorités alors que les
vérités ne sont pas exemptes de tout ça
les fascine ce genre de chose que tu as
raconté cette fois arrivé pour de
l'hybridation de copains oui oui bayal
est en fait globalement l'amélioration
est plutôt safe de manière générale ces
deux des cas assez rare là le cadre du
poids c'est un cas un peu un peu
anecdotique mais
ouais il ya eu des cas de céleri des
variétés qui qui s'est créé et est
beaucoup plus de coups marine qui sont
des composants des véhicules
photosensible et donc il ya des
agriculteurs et des vendeurs qui les
manipulent et qui du coup se mettait ses
coûts marine surhumains et ensuite avec
les uv sa active est entre guillemets la
molécule est ce à cause des irritations
il ya eu une variété de tomates de
patates qui était riche en composés en
du coc alcaloïdes qui sont aussi de
composés toxiques et donc il ya eu des
intoxications du coup la parité avait
été retiré du marché
donc voilà il ya déjà des cadences dans
la sélection classique où il peut y
avoir aussi des problèmes quoi et si tu
veux à revenir dans le passé et par les
attend de toi qui rentrait la fac
qu'est ce que tu dirais je ne sais pas
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de choses en
fait c'est je sais pas si mon mois du
passé s'il me voyait lui dire tout ça
s'il n'aurait pas un effet de 2 comment
dire de 6e braquerait pas et ça ne
comporterait pas de report dans l'idée
opposés non plus je pense que le fait
que ce soit un peu progressif c'est
aussi ça aide aussi peut-être là ça
prend du temps c'est un conte du temps
de se remettre en question du coup
qu'est ce que tu penses que tu fais mal
dans sa communication sur ces sujets
qu'est ce que tu vas la fermer c'est
ouais c'est difficile aussi c'est je
pense que là c'est difficile de
communiquer en fait je pense parce que
bah déjà je communique sur youtube et
sur twitter qu'ils sont et pas forcément
les meilleurs outils peut-être youtube
un peu plus que twitter mais du coup
youtube ça ça permet pas de discuter
vraiment twitter al'inverse ça permet de
discuter mais c'est un peu limité donc
c'est je pense que les outils sont un
peu difficiles mais après il ya près
aussi le fait que sur sur ces réseaux là
ça dépend aussi l'interlocuteur quoi
c'est quand même autre chose si vous
connectant locuteurs qu'ils soient
qu'ils soient ouverts ouais après je
sais que j'ai peut-être un peu tendance
à être un peu agressif parfois à pas
être très très pédagogue
nous avons sur twitter en tout cas pas
plaisir que si c'était il ya dix ans à
qui avaient pris fin il ya 20 ans et pas
twitter où je n'avais pas vu que c'était
encore plus compliqué de communiquer
surtout en tant qu'étudiant thèse
[Rires]
qu'est ce que tu penses que tu fais bien
ou mieux qu'avant c'est difficile je
pense que ouais je pense que j'arrive je
vais peut-être un peu plus de recul sur
moi-même sur bas justement là ce que je
peux te dire que la communication que je
fais n'étaient pas idéales
j'avais peut-être pas forcément ce recul
là je me questionne peut-être un peu
plus sur des meilleurs moyens de le
faire je pense que j'essaie de réfléchir
là à mieux communiquer quoi c'est un
énorme déficit qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
faire qu'est-ce qu'est ce que on pourra
faire jouer entre ceux qui pensent que
vous êtes
ça reste un moindre mal et crisogène
faudra faire la charge je suis qu'est ce
que cette communauté de gens devraient
faire
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire pour
mieux communiquer quelle communauté je
veux dire les scientifiques et
scientifique
oui à part à part essayer de communiquer
de d'être transparent de montrer
expliquer bien bas la méthode
scientifique déjà puisqu'elle comment
fonctionne la science ensuite expliqué
les résultats qu est ce qu on a presque
une étude montre qu est-ce qu on est tu
ne montres pas ce que ça c'est déjà une
bonne chose après il ya aussi il ya
aussi faim c'est tout un système khwaja
il ya les médias aussi qui qui favorise
tout où toute cette atmosphère un peu un
peu de défiance il ya aussi je sais pas
peut-être qu'il ya un manque de deux
d'enseignement scientifique dans dans le
primaire et le secondaire peut-être que
non devrait être formé un peu plus tôt à
ça donc c'est tout un c'est tout un
système qui a changé ses fins et
beaucoup de facteurs et c'est très
difficile c'est un manque de
valorisation de la science oui surtout
des clés cd suis un peu politique c'est
ça c'est pas facile a argué france était
qu un autre truc qui qui est important
parce qu'on parle beaucoup de la science
mais je pense qu'il ya un autre truc et
qui est important c'est essayer de les
gens armés c'est pas un peu du recul sur
leurs convictions leur idéologie
parce que quand quand on est dedans on
peut être persuadé que la chose qui
m'est si c'est difficile de te faire un
peu en arrière de se demander mais
pourquoi est-ce que je suis convaincu
que ça s'est bien passé
il faut il faut c'est un travail à faire
sur soi c'est difficile à faire pipi
il ya aussi quelque chose à faire au
niveau de faire de la communauté des
gens qui communiquent sur sur ces sujets
on n'aura pas un petit peu de co2 enfin
on a pas mal parlé tout à l'heure de ce
documentaire est ce que je pense que
c'est une des plus grosses cheats tarn
qui a eu sur twitter et francophone paul
en tout cas c'est celle de vue assez
énorme et ça fait ça fait depuis janvier
et ça continue encore et ça fait
vraiment de détention assez énorme
moi j'ai un petit peu peur que à cause
de ça ça ça plus enfin bon ça braken
orient de jean mix est un fossé qui
s'est créé renforcer quoi plutôt qu est
peut-être un peu après après il ya
généralement c'est que les gens qui sont
très opposées tu auras beau même essayé
de discuter avec eux en leur offrant
enfin pas de bien discuter en disant est
ce qu'elle est ce que tu es capable de
changer d'avis et c'est ce genre de
personnel à ce genre de personne n'a
ainsi elles sont très opposées elles
sont en cause il n'y a rien qui leur
fera changer d'avis quoi donc du coup
tout ce que tu leur diras ne fera que
les conforter dans leur position après
il ya cet entre deux de personnes qui
n'ont pas forcément d'avis ou qui se
questionne un peu mou qui savent pas et
c'est peut-être plus ces personnes là
qui qui y verront peut-être un peu les
arguments des deux côtés qu'ils iront
aux quais vont ces arguments d'un mètre
de ce côté là il me semble un peu plus
fondée il ya des études l'autre côté là
c'est un peu c'est un peu des attaques
gratuites ou je sais pas et peut-être
que ces personnages sont le ne peut être
le public à assembler ouais ouais je
pense que c'est clairement un public il
faut viser c'est pas facile mais c'est
le problème avec ces sujets qui sont
très polarisée et puis notre marque a
versé que rossi depuis janvier c'est ça
sa brosse à fait six mois même pas toi
tu as fait ton temps pour changer d'avis
ça prend des années avec à bord un peu
visé impressions sur le long terme aussi
attaqué oui mais c'est une nécessité que
globalement assez c'est le début et que
fight xrt s'agit-t-il bonne pratique
certaines réflexions est-ce qu'elles
sont à d'autres de crainte autre
critique récurrente qu'on te fais eu des
critiques récurrentes
enfin la plupart cessé d un succès des
trucs lente et entre les tours à présent
temps il ya des critiques qui sont
intéressantes c'est par exemple dans une
vidéo où le débat sur ce point là il ya
aussi ça tu peux voir ça de ce que tu
dis là ce n'est pas forcément vrai et
c'est super intéressant parce que du
coup ça va ça permet aussi de remettre
en question de dire ah ouais c'est vrai
que j'avais pas vu ça sous cet angle là
tu murs un peu ton propos même si tu
cherches pas complètement a vitupéré ça
permet de nuancer d'étoffer un peu et
c'est beaucoup plus enrichissant quoi
mais là c'est le premier décret du coup
c'est ce genre de critique a été un peu
plus rares et un peu noyé dans une masse
il dit qu à ça les autres avec un jeu
c'est ce qu'on sait c'est que sur ces
sujets sujet très très chaud parfois
j'ai juste envie de de filtrer tous les
tous les commentaires un peu inutilement
inutile enfin avec qui tout récent
vraiment une pollution du coup extraire
juste les parties intéressantes du débat
mais après on traite à d'élitiste à
chérac que j'essaie de faire
wayne on savait pas sur twitter quand
j'ai ce genre de 2,2 d'insulter tous
enfin j'ai vraiment envie de bloquer la
personne deux fois je me fait d'ailleurs
penser vraiment très insultant et mais
enfin
après tu dis si tu bloques la personne
et à sa valeur encore plus la conforter
dans son truc d'ancizan bahama bloqué
sais que j'ai raison de la décision mais
a cessé sa psy du coup quelques
questions les prochains sujets que tu
compte aborder sûreté chêne accepte know
when enfin c'est plein d'idées mais j'ai
pas forcément le temps mais en vrai
j'aimerais étoffé bas sur ce compte sur
ce dont on n'a pas discuté la de sur les
ogm sur comment sont faits les arrêtés
de manière générale sans que ce soit et
ogm et ce pour avoir comparé
on commence on fait limoger comment sont
faits les objets pour voir qu'il n'ya
pas vraiment de différence ouais ouais
j'avais une idée voulait peut-être parlé
de dégâts ni une chose comme ça ultra
complexe et il faut vraiment beaucoup de
temps donc c'est des choses qui me
prennent du temps
peut-être que ça sortir un jeu parce que
ta vie de ce centre à découvrir
d'allemagne tubes et puis parce que
beaucoup de temps à comment tu vois le
futur sur ces questions tant le débat
autour de lui il faisait des ogm tout ça
c'est un peu pessimiste déjà déjà le
glyphosate il est mort il ya l'opinion
publique elle est faite et il ya très
peu de chance pour changer l'opinion
publique qui va se faire interdire et de
grandes chances dans deux ans mais et
enfin
d'après ça veut pas dire que moi je n'ai
pas vraiment envie de tout abandonner et
d'accepter voilà qu on va continuer à
défaut d'information des choses comme ça
pour justifier sert donc j'essaie quand
même malgré tout 2 voilà de 2d boy qui
est un peu d'expliquer de communiquer
mais enfin c'est je pense que c'est une
cause perdue après sur les ogm j'étais
être un peu plus d'espoir mais c'est
plus difficile c'est difficile on a
l'habitude presque sûr j'ai mis la puce
la place que pour ça je pense surtout
aux surtout avec avec chrysler qui est
arrivé et qui a beaucoup de chercheurs
qui sont qui se sont exprimés quand
quand cette décision de la ce et juan
disons qu'en disant que ça allait
freiner beaucoup de recherches
soutiennent beaucoup chercheurs même pas
forcément dans dans le domaine de
l'amélioration même temps les incidents
mais la biologie animale et humaine et
c'est qui qui sont les souliers sur le
fait que c'est un peu c'est une décision
qui est un peu problématique qui va
poser des problèmes sur la recherche de
la freiner la recherche et qui donc l'a
su je suis peut-être un peu plus un peu
mieux au petit va falloir beaucoup de
d'explication de communication je pense
qu est ce que tu pas du col est fan et
quand est ce que les chercheurs sont
explicités par sur twitter ou sur ceux
qui ont aussi de faire un truc collectif
je sais plus exactement sous quelle
forme et il ya pas mal de deux chantiers
qui se sont regroupés qui ont fait des
des tribunes dans des journaux je pense
il ya déjà eu des des articles dans des
journaux scientifiques aussi comme été
publié je sais pas s'il ya eu des
lettres est là au parlement européen ou
des choses comme ça qui ont été faites
aussi donc pas mal d'action donc dans ce
jour là fait ce que est ce que je vais
avec ses bons avec ses s'est écrasé il
ya peu aussi des risques de
de mauvaise utilisation c'est un truc
qui te préoccupe oui non c'est sûr qu'il
ya des mots il ya des modifications il
peut y avoir des mauvaises utilisations
mais bon c'est pas parce qu'il peut y
avoir des mauvaises utilisations qu'il
faut interdire toutes les utilisations
quoi et c'est là l'intérêt de régulier
de dire ok on évalue au cas par cas on
regarde si ce cas là il pose problème 6
il lui pose pas problème alors ça va on
autorise et puis voilà et alors
peut-être plus grands le futur de la
guinée vers l'agriculture tu penses que
ça ben je pense que va voir des avancées
notamment au niveau mécanique dans la
robotique pour cordes et des techniques
alternatives aux produits
phytosanitaires ou en tout cas pour
réduire grandement les ni les quantités
utilisées
ouais ça c'est quelque chose qui se
développe de plus en plus il ya des des
débuts avec des capteurs qui détectent
là où il ya des mauvaises herbes qui
font un tout petit petit de glyphosate
pied poil à cet endroit là et que ça
évite de dépendre d'une fenêtre partout
dans le champ et c'est vachement plus
précis est vachement plus performant que
est vachement plus écologique aussi que
ce qui est fait à l'heure actuelle après
près dans d'autres améliorations à tout
ce qui s'est déjà fait ça va poursuivre
dans cette voie là je pense des
nouvelles vérités de plus en plus
performantes
même au niveau pesticides dans les
pesticides de moins en moins
problématique de plus en plus optimisée
j'espère ça ça bouge beaucoup la
recherche sur les pesticides et je ne
dépense je sais pas si c'est un peu
c'est au niveau des privés donc c'est un
peu
c'est pas super transparent quoi donc
c'est pas du tout il n'y a pas de
recherche public sur ces questions
pas vraiment l'intéressé de
commercialiser donc au niveau public en
sait on n'a pas vraiment d'intérêt à
commercialiser on va pas commercialisé
par le public n'a pas vocation à faire
du mercantile à vendre des produits
phytosanitaires choses comme ça je pense
et du coup les étés coville a donc plus
tout cas on va se passer si j'étais en
tant que moa agriculture de précision
ces sectes entendez par des robots qui
quittent shit juste là où il faut qu'on
en moyenne 3 pendant deux 2 autres
technologies pas d'inquiétude
le joueur de 28 ans artificiel pour
essayer de voir si les parties du champ
des surveillants temps réel jeu payet et
ronny bien il ya déjà des choses comme
ça il ya des choses comme ça qui sont
déjà en place avec des drones justement
qui qui survolent les champs et qui qui
font de la surveillance pour voir pour
prédire s'il ya une maladie qui va
arriver et pour pour que l'agriculteur
sache les dates ces plans pourquoi pas
si les maladies 6 ap dit qu'il va y
avoir une maladie alors il va il va
préparer les produits phytosanitaires
plutôt que de les utiliser sans savoir
même s'il n'y aurait pas une maladie du
foie comme ça ça permet aussi de
diminuer les quantités mais est-ce que
tu as un peu regardé truc du genre de
fermes verticales des trucs un peu
or ça non je suis pas super renseigner
[Musique]
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas si c'est
si c'est intéressant au niveau
écologique au niveau économique
nouveaux lits l'énergie que ça peut
demander je sais pas du tout ok vin et
du coup est ce que tu vois ce que je
fais ce que je parle aussi d être des
gros problème que tu vois aujourd'hui
pour les sociétés pour le futur de
l'humanité
[Musique]
je pense qu'il ya le problème c'est que
le public
il ya déjà une prise de conscience des
problèmes écologiques de du
réchauffement climatique laisser des
rames et que les solutions qui sont
proposées sont pas sont pas idéales quoi
et je pense qu'il y à un haut niveau
politique a beaucoup de problèmes au
niveau politique quoi il faut que sa
faute ya peut-être un mouvement qui
qu'ils fassent un peu bouger les choses
mais alors monsieur ne vois pas qui
pourrait faire changer les choses quoi
les mêmes les mouvements écologistes
europe ecologie les verts s'est donc y
sont kiki qui vont à l'encontre de
l'environnement parce qu'ils proposent
c'est ça à long terme et à court terme
ce sera une face grenoble
ouais tu penses à l'interdiction du
diffuseur way interdiction du lit faudra
les ogm le nucléaire aussi ça c'est
monsieur je pense qu'alors on n'a pas
assez parlé avec avec roda je sais que
j'en rêve il faut réformer
on a parlé en privé mais ouais c'est ce
que j'ai c'est difficile avec le vent
puis je pense que c'est vraiment
important que l'écologie devienne de
plus en plus faire beaucoup beaucoup
plus scientifique annuelle aujourd'hui
c'est ça mais en fait là tout cas c'est
qu'à la base l'écologie c'est une
science et que
logis est devenu plus politique une
science et qu' elle s'est détachée sa
science quoi ouais mais du coup de clic
est la meilleure stratégie pour rendre
le mouvement écologique plus
scientifique est ce que vaut mieux
s'attaquer aux militants écolos est ce
qu'il vaut que s'il était faire un truc
à côté je pense que les deux et qu'on
peut essayer à essayer de faire prendre
conscience aux militants peu que ce
pourquoi ministre n'est pas forcément
l'idéal mais aussi peut-être que qu'il
ya un mouvement peut-être qui regroupe
des scientifiques des chercheurs qui ont
une certaine ça fait un peu biais
d'autorité mais bon qui suit avec des cd
scientifique ou qui ont un peu une
comment dire la comique qui sont dans le
milieu connu à ce qu'ils disent a quand
même un peu plus de valeur au niveau
scientifique et un mouvement voilà qui
qui propose des solutions en disant
qu'il se base sur la science mais
c'était très vite des échanges avec des
écolos et des bourgs écologistes des
échanges pas vraiment fins et des
échanges un peu et sur twitter des
conversations sur twitter quand même pas
vraiment de discussion juste des
insultes c'est non by cc copier tout ça
[Musique]
c'est tellement les gens veulent faire
finalement la bonne chose mais c'est
juste tellement mal informé sa cage en
quoi c'est que l'intention est bonne
quand même le moyen
[Musique]
et ouais c'est rageant quoi qui est un
énorme excès de confiance ces gens sont
tellement sûrs deux fois oui peut-être
mais je ne sais pas du tout mais
peut-être que je sais pas si par exemple
moi je vais peut-être aussi un essai de
confiance je sais pas ce que c'est un
truc auquel tu fais tu es assez fait
gaffe
j'adore le dvi td biais de confirmation
à céder les pieds dans ce que tu lis way
j'essaye j'essaie je suis conscient en
tout cas déjà ses forces que c'était la
même chose
conscient que j'ai dédié mais c'est
difficile à éviter quoi c'est un peu
c'est un peu en créant tout quoi il faut
essayer de les éviter on voit ça revient
un peu au même
ouais sky des stratégies pour éviter ça
c'est pas déjà je sais que j'ai tendance
à être beaucoup plus critique des études
qui vont montrer le contraire de ce que
je pense
grosbill confirmation et donc du coup
ces études là j'ai vraiment est
décortiqué regarder toute la méthode
tous les résultats toutes les figures
vraiment en détail alors que les études
qui vont à mon sens c'est peut-être plus
tendance à ne pas les îles est
décortiqué l'otan ouais donc ouais mais
elle peut forcer un peu à un avenir plus
a analysé un peu plus ouais je ferai pas
invité aux et je prépare une vidéo qui
sera déjà sorti une éducation de cette
interview sur le cadenas pas
psychologique car on les sceptiques sont
beaucoup beaucoup plus critique de sa
qui ne le serait de un truc de
psychologie
mais c'est pas complètement irrationnel
le d'être beaucoup plus critique parce
que parce que a priori aussi le tweak
est passée un peu la phrase de 15 5 ans
il affirme à son extraordinaire au caire
des preuves puisque puisqu'il
extraordinaire mais il faut faire gaffe
à ne pas tomber dans biais de
confirmation ce qui préface il attend ça
surtout encourager les gens à essayer de
faire de conduire aux cultures cessé de
se réfléchir à pourquoi est ce qu'ils
pensaient qu'ils pensent ce qui est
toujours difficile mais est-ce que tu as
d'autres choses à rajouter
bon ok j'ai deux des rares questions
donc la land art c'est parce que
qu'est-ce que tu voir mû résumé un
message clé que tu aimerais à que les
auditeurs retiennent de cette interview
alors à retenir je pense eux soyez pas
forcément anti ogm anti-pesticides eux
sur des a priori peut-être voilà se
renseigner sur les ce que ça peut
apporter sur les conséquences
conséquence que leurs interactions peut
avoir critiqué est ce que tu vas finir
avec des recommandations de vidéos
podcasts livres aux personnes suivant du
coup personne à suivre vous avez
mentionné je pense les personnes qui ont
été impliquées dans la sphère je dormais
spéciale
donc il ya bien le garder car un blog
d'esprit critique donc il parle de
justement de deux sujets un peu qu'il
faudra tout j'aime et où il parle aussi
d'un sujet fait que là il a fait un
article de son plus récent c'est sur lui
que sur inclusivement prennent à voir
mais c'est super intéressant
aprilia la théière cosmiques sur
laquelle du coup il ya cet article qui
regroupe toutes les critiques et puis
voilà il parle aussi fait globalement
c'est tout ce que tout ce que j'ai six
décès de l'esprit critique
au global métiers eau qui ont traité
aussi ces sujets là il ya donc la chèvre
pensante qui a fait l'analyse sur les
trolls un mondrian qui fait lui d une
vidéo des vidéos youtube où il fait des
critiques médiatiques un peu de sueur
des journaux des articles sont sortis en
montrant pourquoi l'article n'est pas
forcément bon après projets des projets
autopia aussi donc c'est un blog est
aussi une chaîne youtube ou pas pareil
on y traite aussi pesticides
alimentation voilà hockey va super bien
merci
je n'ai pas oublié tant pis pour les
autres
en tout cas et
merci merci aux éditeurs d'avoir suivi
et je vous dis à bientôt probablement
bientôt ciao